cette habitante de chevigny saint
sauveur habite en face du parking où ont
été tirés les coups de feu et donc les
affaires s'est passée la seule partie ni
à droite alors à coups de feu moi j'en
ai entendu qu à espérer qu'elle a eu de
moi j'en ai entendu qu'un à 23h20 donc
ça nous a réveillés le chien achaâcha p
donc on s'est mis sur la terrasse on a
regardé et là on a vu arriver voitures
de police et ambulances pompiers
la résidence beauséjour s'est réveillée
tout redit ce matin les traces au sol
témoignent de la violence des faits hier
soir deux jeunes hommes stationnés ici
ils sont pris pour cible le plus jeune
âgé de 25 ans est touché au cou son
pronostic vital est engagé
le second plus légèrement blessée donne
alerte secours ils sont alors
transportés au chu de dijon
une enquête est ouverte pour tentative
de meurtre une enquête confiée à deux
unités de recherches de la gendarmerie
de dijon pour les habitants de chevigny
saint sauveur ses coups de feu sont
surprenants mouassa quartier résidentiel
apparemment donc il n'y a pas trop de
vin car nous balade en vélo ou notre
promenade en place dans le quartier
j'ai pas
j'ai pas peur de me déplacer dans
chevigny je sais que c'est une ville
calme
pour l'heure aucune personne n'a été
mise en garde à vue règlement de comptes
ou mauvaise rencontre
l'enquêté le déterminera